goes to back up top to love
struce to love Vincent was open in the
corner they didn't get it to the shot
clock winding down oh and Caldwell Pope
thousand with seven tenths of a second
on what was a desperation three-point
heat a rare defensive mistake from
Caldwell Polk
[Applause]
bad play clearly contact by Pope
I'm watching all this action go on and
Kevin Love Miss Gabe Vincent all by
himself in the corner
he went he went and hugged each other no
frowning no point in the finger not
upset but just say I made a mistake I
missed you that's winning mentality and
outstanding culture
alrighty more than double the amount of
free throws from game one
[Applause]
they get Christian Brown a standing
ovation
coming out of the game and love knows
I mean that's a little bit dramatic just
for missing a guy though no no that gave
me goosebumps with some blame at the guy
I missed you we gotta hug it out now
come on man what is wrong with this guy
they've been talking about how Kevin
Love throughout all of this
has been such a terrific leader
obviously with the finals experience
Championship with Cleveland